and that night
changed our city forever
this garden is theirs
and the memories
of course
are ours
anna good evening to you i'm brian
loftis tonight our city reflects on one
october four years later
60 lives were lost countless others have
never been the same we have team
coverage tonight orco mana looks at what
some want to see in a permanent memorial
at the concert grounds but we start with
sasha loftus at the healing garden where
the annual ceremony just wrapped up
sasha
brian the emotion is still palpable here
tonight you can see one candle lit for
everyone who died on this day four years
ago this as we marked another year
remembering those we lost at the las
vegas healing garden
charles hartfield 34 from henderson
nevada
[Music]
las vegas mayor carolyn goodman led
tonight's ceremony which included the
reading of the names of all 58 victims
followed by the toll of a belt and the
lighting of a candle of those of course
survivors and families of those who lost
their lives were here we spoke with one
man who lost a relative that day he
reflected on what this day means to him
there's always different ways to deal
with it everybody has their own ways
counseling
coming to the healing garden
just meeting
other people that was impacted by it
many others we spoke with say it was
their first time seeing the ceremony
here in person now two people later died
from their injuries and brought the
number of lives lost on one october to
60. they were not named during the
candle lighting ceremony but mayor
goodman recognized them separately at
tonight's ceremony reporting live at the
las vegas healing garden tonight sasha
loftis live local now